i know that i say that there's nothing
better than a lot but waking up on
christmas morning or big holiday when
all your family are in town to the smell
of cinnamon rolls is heavenly i mean
there's really nothing better
so this is an old recipe that we kind of
perfected a few years ago when we did
our first homemade cinnamon rolls recipe
a lot of people have made them and had a
lot of comments or questions about the
recipe so we thought this was like a
perfect time to answer those questions
and really make sure that you guys
totally nail it this holiday season
so before we get started what we want to
first do is bloom our yeast but what we
want is warm milk to bloom it in by warm
i just mean if you put your finger into
the milk it shouldn't feel like anything
it should kind of feel like your body
temperature and that's the perfect
temperature it could be a little bit
warmer than that but that's pretty much
what we're going for
we're going to put a little bit of
granulated sugar and that's going to
dissolve in the milk
we're also going to put in some melted
butter so this is going to be an
enriched dough we talked about enriched
doughs when we did the dinner rolls so
it's pretty similar it's just going to
be a little bit sweeter and a little bit
more rich from more butter so we're
going to stir it around just to make
sure that the sugar and the butter are
kind of equally incorporated into the
milk
and then we're going to put a packet of
yeast over this
stir that once more to make sure that
all of the little yeast particles are
totally hydrated we're gonna leave this
to go for about 10 minutes you want to
put this in a pretty warm place so that
the yeast can bloom a cold environment
will slow down the yeast growth what
we're looking for here is like some
bubbles you can see some action it's
actually kind of growing
and to this we're going to add four cups
of flour
it's going to make a really wet messy
dough and that's exactly what we want
[Music]
stir that together to make sure that
everything's equally hydrated we don't
want any flower pockets or anything you
can see at this point it's a little bit
lumpy so i'm just going to stir it a
little bit more until i'm beating out a
few of those lumps
it doesn't need to be totally smooth at
this point it just needs to be kind of
brought together and homogeneous
so once i'm happy i'm going to cover
this with cling film and let it rise for
an hour
again if you're not seeing much growth
move it to a warmer part of your kitchen
that should help a little bit
while this rises let's butter our tins
as with cakes or baking or whatever you
want to make sure that you're ready to
go so just take one of the butter
wrappers and rub it all over the inside
of your tin just to make sure that the
rolls won't stick after they come out of
the oven
and now let's move on to make the
filling
[Music]
and our filling consists of light brown
sugar
very softened butter can't emphasize
that enough
[Music]
and cinnamon
[Music]
in our original video we put on the
softened butter and then the brown sugar
and cinnamon separately it's actually a
lot easier if you just combine them all
and then spread them on evenly and
you're not having any parts that don't
have one of those ingredients
[Music]
so we're happy here it's just a little
bit less than doubled in size
the yeast is definitely alive in this
dough you can see all these little
bubbles here um so you can just poke it
if you want just because it's always fun
to poke brisindo and at this point we're
going to add the other cup of flour
the baking powder
and the salt and we're adding salt to
this of course as a flavor enhancer it's
not going to make the dough salty just
going to enhance all the flavors that
we're going to put into it later
it's going to seem really dry at first
but what we're going to keep doing stir
this as best as we can it's going to be
the scraggly dough at first it's gonna
seem really dry but trust me there's
plenty of liquid in this dough it's
gonna become sticky again before you
know it
one of the comments that we saw on our
original cinnamon roll video people
thought they needed a lot of extra flour
and i just want to encourage you guys
bread dough actually wetter is better so
try to use the least amount of flour
that you can i'm going to put a little
bit of bench flour on the side of my
board here and i don't really want to
use it all this should be enough to
knead our dough as well as roll it out
later so don't use too much of it if you
don't need to all of these little bits
on the side those will come together in
the dough so you can see it's pretty
sticky at this point
the humidity in the air how old your
flour is all of that will determine how
much extra flour that you need
we made this dough five or six times and
sometimes we needed a lot of extra flour
and sometimes we didn't so it's kind of
up to you the more that you make these
the easier this will become i just want
you to be aware that you want to use the
least amount of flour i can't say it
enough that you need so it's the same
process that you would do any other
kneading technique and however you want
to do it is up to you i kind of fold
push and twist and what you're really
trying to do is just work every part of
the dough
as you can see the dough is sticking to
the board quite a lot as well as my
hands and that's just a sign that i do
in fact need more flour
so i'm going to sprinkle a little bit
over a little on the board as well work
that in before i add any more
you really want to be kneading for about
10 minutes until the dough is super
smooth it is bouncing back when you push
your finger into it once i'm happy with
this part we are ready to roll so go
ahead and scrape off the table make sure
you're working with a clean surface put
a little bit of extra flour out because
we don't want our dough sticking to the
board and at this point i'm going to
stick my fingers in start to stretch it
out a little bit you want to get it into
the shape that you're going for as early
as you can because we need it so well
and it's an enriched dough it's actually
really easy to work with and it'll
stretch without tearing too much this is
actually a perfect thing to do in the
winter because you don't want the dough
especially at this point to be too warm
so it'll make it a little bit harder to
work with
i'm always pulling and i'm using my
bench scraper or if you have like a
spatula at home and you can use a lot of
different things anything that's
straight i just want to make sure that
we have pretty tight corners so when we
get to that stage it's just going to be
much easier to work with if you're
working with a really nice rectangle
shape i actually like to plop the
filling down in little sections instead
of kind of putting it all in one place
and then moving it around it's just a
lot easier to spread you can see that
i'm really spreading this all the way to
the edge if you have an even layer
you'll get a really really nice shape as
well when you roll it up so take your
time here it's really satisfying to
spread because it's like so buttery
honestly
whichever way you want to work left or
right right to left we want to start on
one edge and be as even as you can take
your time here so we have a really nice
roll
if you use the length of your hand to
help push it or even at some points i
was using my forearm you want to make
sure that you're getting a really even
tight roll all the way and then use the
weight of that roll to close that seam
and if there's a particularly fat part
of the roll you can kind of spread it a
little bit with your hands and kind of
stretch it ever so slightly because you
want to make sure that the roll is
really even so that your rolls rise
really evenly and they bake evenly as
well
one hack that we learned after making
these so many times is to use dental
floss to cut the rolls because the
dental floss actually cuts the entire
slice from the outside in whereas a
knife kind of pushes from the top down
and squishes the slices
[Music]
it ensures that you get a perfect spiral
with your slices when it's done if
they're not really holding their shape
go ahead and throw them in the fridge
for five or ten minutes and then kind of
roll them between your hands a little
bit to make sure that you're getting a
good shape and then put them into your
butter tins
[Music]
this is kind of as much as you can fit
in there you don't want to jam pack them
too much because these are going to
expand a little bit more once we approve
them
proofing is just kind of like that
second rise before they go into the oven
so it's okay there's a little bit of
space here the rolls will expand a
little bit
[Music]
we're going to cover these with a towel
and let these approve for about 35 to 45
minutes
this is a good place if you were doing
these ahead of time to freeze them so
before they proof cover them with cling
film put them in the freezer these can
stay in the freezer up to three months
and then when you're ready for them you
can defrost them in the fridge overnight
or you can leave them out for a few
hours at room temperature go ahead and
throw them in the oven they might take a
little bit longer depending how cold
they are when you put them in but just
keep an eye on them they're still like
just as good out of the freezer so
proofing is going to give you those
really fluffy rolls so this is an
important step like you don't want to
skip this
so you want your rolls to have expanded
by up to half of their original size
this is going in at 350 degrees
fahrenheit for about 25 to 30 minutes
keep an eye on them the outer ones will
cook a little bit faster so you want to
make sure that that middle one is cooked
through if they are getting too dark on
the top and not cooking on those seams
just go ahead and turn the oven down to
like 3 20 to finish off the cooking so
they don't brown too much while our buns
are in the oven we're gonna make the
frosting
you could just do a basic powdered sugar
water glaze if you wanted to but it's
the holiday so let's bump it up a little
bit we're gonna add cream cheese you
know we love it adds a little tanginess
cuts the sweetness a little bit melted
butter and we're going to use milk and
vanilla to flavor our icing we want to
use powdered sugar here instead of
granulated sugar because it's so much
more finely ground that's going to make
sure that the sugar dissolves really
easily in the liquids so go ahead and
get all of your ingredients into the
bowl first except for the powdered sugar
we want to make sure that all these
ingredients are very well creamed
together and there's no lumps before we
add the powdered sugar
seriously seriously make sure that your
cream cheese is room temperature like
very soft it'll just incorporate so much
easier if it's pretty warm this is a
really good standard cream cheese recipe
because it's not too cream cheesy i
don't like when it's too cream cheesy so
this is the perfect amount of cream
cheesiness
so once everything's very smooth we're
gonna gradually add our powdered sugar
just add like a little bit at a time
especially when you get started and this
is just to ensure again that there's no
lumps
if you are the type of person that
really loves icing you could make double
of this so you just got to tell us in
the comments if this was enough icing
for you and your family
and there's your perfectly smooth
perfectly runny icing so you'll be able
to pour this right over the hot rolls
and it'll be perfection
once they come out of the oven you want
to make sure that you're not putting the
glaze on when they're too hot leave them
to cool like at least 10 minutes because
if you put the icing on when it's too
warm the icing is just going to
completely melt and it's not going to be
like that really nice glaze on top and
now for the fun part the drizzling over
i start on the outside and go towards
the middle but it's kind of up to your
preference how much you like you know
drowning and icing if you only like a
little bit
you can use the back of a spoon to kind
of spread the rest of the icing out just
so that every little nook and cranny
gets a little bit of icing
you could also just put this on the
table and let people put their icing on
it themselves if you want
this is like
gorgeous i mean look at that icing on
those rolls
ugh all that hard work and look how
beautiful like this is super smooth
icing over these warm cinnamon rolls i
mean i just wish you guys could smell
these if you smelled this you guys would
immediately go and make these cinnamon
rolls like they smell so so good this is
one of our original tasty recipes that
we just really love and have become
family favorite here at tasty so we hope
you enjoy them as much as we did
[Music]
i just wish you guys could smell these i
really how are we who's gonna invent
like a smell-o-vision like we have to
have this for you guys
[Music]